-Guys, it is time for "Tonight
Show" hashtags! Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week, and I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys
to respond to that topic
on Twitter and all the socials.
So since the royal family
has been in the news,
I sent out the hashtag
#MyFamilyIsWeird,
where I ask you guys
to tweet out
something funny or weird
about your family.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic all day,
so thank you for playing along.
These are some of my favorites.
Now I thought I'd share some
of my favorite "my family is
weird" responses from you guys.
And, man, there's some
weird families out there.
This first one is from
@Danielle-Nellie.
She says...
[ Laughter, applause ]
That's a good bit, man.
I love that.
I love that family.
That's funny.
This one's from @margefootball.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Again, that's so funny.
That would make me laugh.
I'd love that.
I'm gonna do all these things.
This one's from pinkeyegus.
That's unfortunate.
-Mm.
-He says...
-Oh, no!
[ Cymbal crashes ]
[ Laughter ]
Ah.
-That is such a funny bit, man.
This is a great one.
-No, it's not.
-This a great hashtag.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @JulieKessler5.
She says...
-[ Laughing ] What?
[ Laughter, applause ]
-That's a waste of pancakes.
-What? No,
they're leftover, man.
-You're gonna start
doing that one.
-I will. Yeah, I will.
Thanks for those pancakes,
by the way.
-Oh, God.
-This one's from @TedBrogan2.
He says...
[ Laughter, applause ]
"You don't know
what that branch --"
Wow.
Jesus.
-Say it again?
-[ Shouting indistinctly ]
[ Laughter ]
-"Want to warn me next time?!
Branch was not
bothering anybody."
[ Laughter ]
-Sorry, man.
-Hey, God, we're good, man.
[ Voice breaking ]
Favorite -- My favorite branch.
This one here's from hackysac35.
She says...
Here is the original photo.
And here are the kids'
recreations.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
That's really funny, man.
[ Chuckles ]
That's a good family.
This one's from @skoalmcrae.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
A bit of an overreaction,
there, Dad.
I'm sure they'll have oysters
the next time we come back.
-Yeah, geez.
-"Never gonna --
Yeah, when hell freezes over
I'll come back to your place."
Okay. Come on, buddy.
This one's from @stephsloser.
She says...
Here's a photo.
Oh.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Literally.
-Yeah.
This last one here
is from jmumz87.
She says...
Oh, here we go.
Hey, there you have it.
There are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.